after his lame attempts to answer his
critics Joe Biden spent the rest of the
time on the view discussing what was
really the focal point of his campaign
launch video the Charlottesville events
in August of 2017 I wrote an article at
the time and the Atlantic magazine back
when Charlotte show happened in saying
that you know this this is not who we
are there's an American creed it's about
decency honor
including everyone leaving no one behind
I just it was like I don't remember that
ever happening in an administration
before and a long and well over a
hundred years now the president's
looking to relitigate all of this what
they see is a troubling moment for
President Trump today they pressed him
on his way to the NRA convention watch
you look at what I said you will see
that that question was answered
perfectly and I was talking about people
that went because they felt very
strongly about the monument to robert e
lee a great general whether you like it
or not it'll react is Candace Owens
communications director for Turning
Point USA and shavar Jeffries president
of Democrats for education reform ladies
gentlemen
is this a legitimate campaign opener for
Biden and your reaction to the
president's comments there I'll start
with you shavar well there's absolutely
legitimate issue I mean the
Charlottesville incident really spoke to
the character of President Trump he said
that there was blame to go along on both
sides when it clearly went white
nationalist white supremacist who caused
a death of a person connected to that
incident so it's absolutely legitimate
issue race unfortunate has been a major
fault line in our country and we need a
president we'll bring this country
together not tear it apart Candace your
take on that I mean shavar just
reiterated what Biden said that the
president called white supremacists fine
people is that what really happened
that's exactly not what happened and you
can go and you can look up the full
speech of what Trump said he
specifically said I am NOT speaking
about white supremacist or Nazis so this
is not a legitimate issue at all and
what's really bizarre is that Joe Biden
of all people would use this as a way to
launch his campaign this is a man
who was mentored by Robert Byrd a
literal KKK member this is a man that
said that black people should remain
segregated in 1972 because it's what we
wanted he has issues with black America
and I'm really happy to see that people
on both sides in the political aisle
black Americans that are Democrat and
Republican have spoken up and pointed
out his hypocrisy I want to get your
thoughts on this CNN's van Jones thinks
that Biden planted a perfectly laid trap
for the president watch we've got him
right where he wants him already
but it's business it's really really
it's so painful to hear the commander in
chief the present United States sit up
here and brag on a traitor brag on
someone who is committing an act of
treason to defend one of the most
abominable institutions in the history
of the world it's painful it's wrong
it's wrong headed it's beneath him it's
beneath the office of the president but
from a political point of view Joe Biden
just showed the world he knows how to
put a banana peel in front of Donald
Trump and watch him fall Candice's Biden
really laid a banana peel for the
president to fall upon no I think this
is just more leftist illusion if I'm
being honest like there is not a single
candidate that is going to beat
president Donald Trump and that is just
the truth they have nothing that's new
to me Joe Biden is the new Hillary
Clinton they're all going to celebrate
him they're going to claim the polls
here that he's highly favored when in
fact he is not he's not at all and
people understand that he does not have
any policies you know he's just doing
more fear-mongering and he's being
hypocritical and America is not going to
fall for it because we are all doing
much better
under this president than we were doing
under Obama shavar is this really what
the african-american community is
looking for in a candidate sort of
identity politics and you know there's a
racist there this guy's a racist and I'm
not is that enough given that you have
historically low poverty rates among
African Americans criminal justice
reform from Trump what what are
african-americans really looking for in
your opinion well first of all the
unemployment trends we see today start
with President Obama after in the
aftermath of the bush recession the
African American unemployment rate was
17% when President Obama left off his
eight and a half percent under the bush
recession the Latino unemployment rate
reached 13% it was less than 6% under
President Obama so yes we've seen some
incremental
in the last couple years on the truck
but most of those trends started under
President Obama the president Trump has
dismantled the Affordable Care Act which
affects working families across this
country disproportionately people of
color he made very clear when he came
down an escalator he called brown people
Mexicans rapists criminals he said some
of them might be nice people and that
sort of character that sort of
racialized characters what we've seen
from this president for a long period of
time what about criminal justice reform
and I want both of you to react yes
you're Democrats and the President Obama
talked about this we heard about it
talked about throughout his
administration it was never enacted
nothing was done Hammond's okay look
look I would say this black Americans
are tired of being undermined that
that's best evidenced by the fact that
despite all of the rhetoric despite the
media trying to label Trump as a white
supremacist black support Donald Trump
has doubled since he stepped into office
black Americans are waking up we are
tired of people issuing an emotional
response Donald Trump we want people to
offer policies that are going to fix our
community unfortunately it's only Trump
that is offering policies out of the
candidates on the left are offering any
new policies and you're going to see
that in 2020 I've predicted over and
over again that President Donald J Trump
is going to be the person that cracks
the black vote because we are tired we
are fatigued with the racial argument
chiavari you do see numbers in support
from african-americans rising for Trump
to what do you attribute that first of
all I'm not often emotional more in
facts President Trump just this year
sought to cut over two hundred billion
dollars from the student loan program
over 200 but dollars for two hundred
billion dollars excuse student loans
affect everybody Hispanics white Xavier
Chinese American they disproportionately
affect working poor people nets
disproportionately people of color a
present from will not win don't make it
so that's dishonest blacks don't make it
to effect white people I mean I'd like
to finish under President Obama I'm
sorry well I'm gonna correct you now
under President Obama we saw record
numbers of black people attend and
graduate from college completion rates
went up record the majority majority
people that attend college or white I
just want to cry
that's of course because there's
dramatically more white people in this
country but the rates of black people
graduating have gone up the high school
graduation rates went up that would
impact white America finish wealthy for
black folks went up again when President
Obama was elected we're after map that
the worst recession since the Great
Depression triggered by the economic
policies of Republican President Bush
african-american unemployment weights
went down by fifty percent under
President Obama Latino unemployment
rates went down by fifty percent under
President Obama because I know but it's
at historic lows now and you didn't give
you plenty time question why are black
Americans now rising in their support of
Donald Trump you got five seconds well
they could go to nowhere but I mean he
was close to zero in 2016 so they may go
up incremental e but he's gonna lose
african-american and Latino voters not
question about that no he's not black
people aren't stupid and we're getting
tired of the race mongering we're doing
well under this president we are going
to vote another half hour with just the
two of you thank you so much for being
here and for your perspective